وكشفت الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه عن فوز
اردوغان باحدى وخمسين مقاطعه مقابل 30
لمرشح المعارضه كمال كليجدار اوكلو في
تفاصيل ذلك خسر اردوغان اهم مقاطاعتين
وهما اسطنبول وانقر بعد انتصار اوغلو
فيهما بفارق ضئيل كذلك تمكن مرشح المعارضه
من السيطره على جميع المقاطعات شرق تركيا
تقريبا وبعض الولايات في الجنوب الغربي
بينما سيطر اردوغان على مقاطعات الوسط
والشمال ابرزها واكبرها مقاطعه قونيا وكان
لافتا ايضا فوزا كليجدار اوغلو في بعض
الولايات التي تضررت بنكبه الزلزال مثلها
طاي واضنه بينما فاز اردوغان في ولايات
اخرى متضرره كشارلي اورفا وغازي عنتاب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات